[Music]  lady gaga gets emotional at the 2022  grammy awards  [Music]  the 36 year old singer even tears up  during her performances of love for sale  and do i  [Music]  the performances followed a surprise  introduction in a pre-taped video from  iconic singer and frequent gaga  collaborator tony bennett hi everyone  please welcome  lady gaga  at the end of her set gaga sends tony a  message of her own i love you tony we  miss you  leading up to the big night gaga and  bennett were celebrating multiple nods  for their latest album  and i suddenly turn and see  your  fabulous face and gaga isn't going home  empty-handed they won two grammy awards  including best traditional pop vocal  album  the honors follow bennett giving his  final life performance in august he was  diagnosed with alzheimer's disease in  2016.  gaga was on hand for the concert at  radio city music hall  [Music]  get my kicks out of you  [Music]  you